foreign
[Music]
here we go guys
um it is the week of August it's August
what the heck how did that happen it's
August and also we are going to be in
Charlotte North Carolina Knoxville
Tennessee Nashville we got a bunch of
these coming up it's actually crazy that
um you get tickets at chrisley.com but
it's crazy that it's already August and
I'm I'm now I'm hitting tour hard again
um I'll be in Irvine and Brea coming up
also just to work some new stuff out
Little Rock Arkansas that's the one
Calgary Alberta you know that's all and
Australia I know I'm just chill I'm
coming I'm figuring it out uh
crystallia.com and with uh that being
said
um oh there's also a new uh there's a
bunch of merch you've got the pockets
stay deep merch we got the
um with the little diving boards on the
pocket there looks really nice and then
we got the uh the different life rips
colorways and the grower die uh new
stuff which is awesome we love in the
grower die stuff saw people out with it
the other day uh but anyway further uh
without further Ado kind of hating when
people say that but I said it uh let's
do the newest episode of congratulations
[Music]
you're crazy congratulations
I'm in my freaking tattoo era dude I
gotta keep I gotta keep getting these
tattoos man I got another one I got two
more wow I got 16. whatever what are we
gonna do and then pretty and you know
what next tattoo I'm not gonna say I got
this many I'm not gonna say I have 17.
I'm just gonna say I've got I'm tattooed
hey how many do you have I just go like
this dude you know just look at me
and I rip off my shirt with just one arm
like Hulk Hogan used to do
um even when it's a heavy heavy shirt
because that's how freaking because I
also work out a lot so how crazy is that
um not crazy
um we got a a bunch of crowd work Clips
up on my thing
um the Pueblo one or wait no not the
puebloon I don't know they're doing well
but go over my YouTube page Chrisley
YouTube
um and uh yeah dude but I have a lot of
this chair is definitely broken so
that's great there's always something
broken right
um yeah I got all these tattoos dude I'm
never gonna stop I'm getting a chess
piece what the f dude they're gonna go
They're gonna see me in this at the end
of the summer they're gonna go like this
he did he did it again dude that's it
they're gonna go like that they're going
to see me drive by with my arm out the
window no shirt after the gym they're
gonna be like he did it again
didn't he he's got a whole chess piece I
mean what the f
it's like he's uh
battle He-Man or whatever that was when
you used to hit the thing
and uh and the the chess used to change
whatever that was I don't remember uh
but yeah dude so that's it and uh I've
been working out and I have tennis elbow
or you know what I'm gonna call it
climber's elbow because I got it after I
went rock climbing yes dude the tendons
didn't catch up to my muscles yes man so
now the tendons are sore and you can't
do anything to get them better yes dude
looked up some YouTube videos to see if
I can get them better of course I did
and then what were they saying to do do
the exercises that absolutely hurt my
thing so now it's making it worse yeah
so I don't do it awesome do it I got
tennis elbow climbers slash climbers
elbow yes dude
how much does it hurt not enough to stop
working out why because we go for it
dude we've seen too many David Goggins
video David Goggins videos
we've seen too many David Goggins videos
to give up that simple a little bit of
elbow pain we worked through it is it
bad for the body maybe but it's good for
the mind dude because we keep going now
is it good for the mind yes because we
can persevere and get through it yes do
we stop working out after just one
little thing hurts no we don't do that
and does that is that confirm until yes
and then later on is it bad for a mental
because we dwell on an es but it doesn't
matter because we also have good
fundamental before that dude so it's
also good and you know it's a good and
the bad it's again in the gang really is
what it is
it's the yin and the Yang my babies
um
but yeah dude uh
uh and I guess also there's aliens
hey so it doesn't matter really if your
elbow hurts right because there's aliens
and now now people are just going to be
like oh what do you think about people
just gonna ask me stuff now what do you
think about black lives matter there's
aliens dude so it's like
what do you think of the the you know
the trans movement there's aliens I
don't
what's the matter there's aliens
and guess what
the guy said under oath and Senate they
do harm so what's the matter huh
they're piloting they're out piloting
were they human when she says were they
human and he says they were not human
well specify could they have been dogs
um just tell why are they always so
cagey about it right it's so annoying
this is we're here because we want you
to be specific and we're there human
remains they were not human remains dude
you know how she wants you to answer the
question
what was it yeah
were there human remains I I am I I
don't know there were not human remains
what were there not human remains okay
did you put it on the thing
the aliens under the aliens thing or is
it new oh non- oh he said non-human bio
biologics like dude just say are there
aliens or not
what was in the thing uh they were
aliens with beady eyes they look like
the thing on the cover of that book that
old book communion
so annoying dude
look at look at look at former military
officials and then people are like we
need proof well of course we need proof
man if you got crazy claims you need
crazy proof I want to see that alien
going through the friggin uh Wendy's
drive-through I want to see
former military officials made a series
of mystifying claims about an
unidentified aerial phenomenon phenomena
uh under oath that Wednesday's
Congressional hearing
the hill uh today held a hearing on
unidentified aerial phenomena also known
as uaps or so when did they start this
UAP [__]
you're going to switch it now and now
that they're they're admitting it UFO
UAP unidentified aerial phenomena why
this is like is this like
are they protesting out there we are not
UFOs we are aerial phenomena we are not
unidentified flying objects flying is
derogatory We Are Ariel we identify as
aerial phenomenon not flying objects
that is objectifying us literally
calling us objects we are aerial
phenomena okay dude
why do they start that [__] that's so
annoying well I change it when the
shit's real now that's super annoying
dude
I don't mean to be hate I'm not hating
but it's like I'm still with that UFO
[__] I'm old school dude people are
gonna call me racist alien racist UFOs
alien racism rolling public interest
about potential extrator hey guys shave
your head this guy already you know
committee her testimony from three
Witnesses today one was a former Navy
commander and the other guy was a former
Navy pilot Aaron both of them to have
seen uaps as well as intelligence
officer step further and he alleged that
the government
well dude no [__] man it's like they
didn't just show up today
I would be there have been aliens all
over the place all the time
and I don't I'm not look I'm not saying
there's aliens or there's not aliens but
there's aliens you know what I'm saying
like there's definitely aliens because
we're not the only things in the
atmosphere that are like you know
bumping into walls and [__] UAP I won't
stand for that I stop with the UAP [__]
I won't stand for that I'm not the only
being on the planet that like hits his
hip on the side of an end table and goes
ah
we're not the only beings that do that
okay there's absolutely
people who do that that take UFOs and a
retrieval program
take a listen to more of what this here
we go
if you believe we have crashed crash
here's let me just this is how they
should just answer the show earlier do
we have the bodies of the pilots who
piloted this craft as I've stated
publicly already in my news Nation
interviews so dick as I've stated it
already in my news interview so dick so
pissed off he's here some of these
recoveries were they I guess
or non-human biologic no they weren't
human we're talking about aliens right
that's why I'm here that's me answering
the question non-human and that was the
assessment of people with direct
knowledge on the program I talked to
that are currently still on the program
I mean so many words dude
non-human biologics
AKA alien for its part the Pentagon
rejected those claims for its parts
Chevy head
um
non-human biologics mimicking up all
sorts of new words now that this shit's
going on this is a distraction you know
I don't know if I believe that but this
is a distraction that's what everybody's
saying now this is a distraction because
there's an election coming up this is a
distraction Trump's going to get out
there and be like aliens we'll kill them
all and everyone's gonna be like [__]
yeah we'll kill them all we'll kill all
the aliens and then he's secretly gonna
move that into adding Mexicans into that
category you know
let's build a wall and some tasers
that's going to be his new platform
um
yeah so
I just wonder how the [__] Liberals
are gonna spin this alien thing you know
I I can't imagine how these liberals
are going to spin this alien thing
because it's coming
mark my words it's coming we need to no
hey dude let's just do this okay and if
this is what it takes me if the aliens
are hearing this I'm sorry but dude
I'm racist when it comes to aliens stay
on your own [__] planet okay yeah I
don't give a [__] even if you look like
us stay over there I'm racist when it
comes to aliens all right
I'm gonna die racist coming I don't want
look if you want people if you want
Mexicans to come over the Border Great I
don't get you know I don't know I don't
really know the whole Logistics of it
but what I do know is when I meet a
Mexican illegal or not I go like this
hey man so cool to meet you nice to I
hope you have a good day right I'm not
racist when it comes to aliens dude if
we're gonna start to integrate because
the Liberals you know that you know
where uh
you know 15 20 years away from like just
liberals being like they're people too
and the aliens are just like we are not
people they don't even know we are not
people but let that it's cool because at
least we get to go to Target this way
we don't have Target on our planet
and um
and uh
so but when I see aliens I'm gonna do
all sorts of racial alien slurs like
that's the kind of guy I am that's who I
am I'm the down south
oh
racist alien guy
you know crystallia yeah oh he fell off
after the aliens came to Earth and now
we're all accepting the aliens he
doesn't accept them dude he tries to go
out and actively kill them he says it's
in self-defense but really he's acting
them on that's what I do with the aliens
um
you [__] me board
you [__] me board get these me Boards
out of here or whatever the nude slang
is
we didn't do anything to you get on your
own [__] planet man it's our [__]
ting
we didn't do anything to you we just won
equal rights
[__] you me board
I'm intercollet I'm intergalactically
Republican
I'm so intergalactically Republican I'm
a Centrist when it comes to the world
and America but bro when it comes to
intergalactics I'm so Republican it's
ridiculous
I only think that aliens should marry
other sex aliens and this the second an
alien Amelia in
has sex with another male alien dude
that is against the Bible
[__] me boards
there's aliens who cares about
whatever's going on
and we knew there was aliens we knew the
whole time we knew
ah
I don't know what to do about this alien
thing though
you know
saying it does not currently have nor in
the past had any extraterrestrial
materials line comes as more lawmakers
of course they're going to say that dude
by the way I don't I don't even think
they should have admitted this now
publicly
you know how many idiots out there are
going to turn this into something that's
like so much like dude we're fine
they're not gonna take they're not you
think aliens are just all of a sudden
come here like now in the next week and
just oh no shrink us down to you know
pocket size and [__] what the [__]
oh
I'm intergalactically racist dude I'm
intergalactically Republican
I'm intergalactically alt-right
um
I don't know though man it's fine
Kristen was like should we she was like
should we connect to the thing when we
were flying
she was like should we connect or should
we go and stay in New York a little bit
and just take the get the first class
lay down beds and I was like
what are you asking me and she's like
well one is way more expensive and I was
like do it what the [__] there's
aliens you know spend it
I bought Prada overalls spend it
I bought some hey dude there's aliens
okay I'm going to Prada dude there's
aliens I bought Prada uh the second I
learned there were aliens I got Prada
overalls that's it
and they're off white oh
they're cream
you think I'm gonna wear them with a
shirt bro when I get that chess piece
I'm gonna put that [__] on it's gonna be
crazy man
your why your wives are gonna have to
[__] bring towels what do they see
just in case I might be out but they
don't want to slip and fall and hurt
themselves right
I'm gonna be [__] ridiculous with
that chess piece in the [__] overalls
oh they're gonna say oh he did it again
again that's what they're gonna say
um but anyway dude so there's aliens and
it's all good speaking of which not even
it has nothing to do with speaking a
witch but dude I got this but the
electric electric electric bicycle from
Super 73 and I'm ripping all over town
on it super 73 I gotta I'm gonna do an
Instagram post about it but super 73
makes the illest bicycles I'm not paid
to say this dude
super 73 if you want the uh uh I was I
did the George Janko podcast he had a
super 73 bicycle uh um what do you call
it an electric bike and I go what what
is this he's like take a ride I was like
I don't know I don't wanna he goes hop
on I hopped on me I went down I did a
block I was like yo I gotta get one of
these so I got one and they are
absolutely ripping you can do jumps the
tires are so fat you feel so cool dude
they have hydraulics and all that they
got a lamp on the front a headlight you
could turn it on at night bro I ride it
and I'm so cool in it
I ride it and I'm sexy in it
I pedal when I want I don't have to
Pedal electric bikes are the the best so
thank you super 73 for uh making these
absolute beauties
ah it's black on black Like My Rari it's
so cool I'm cool
uh
uh so anyway
um but yeah there's aliens
isn't that crazy
what's up with so all of a sudden X is
gonna be what it is
Twitter is not Twitter anymore dude like
is the media and stuff are they calling
it X now
uh Elon on what that how could you dude
how could you just do that just call it
Twitter still
you know
we all decided it was Twitter and it's
Twitter it's been Twitter for [__] 15
years and now the guy who owns it is
just like it's X now dude we still call
Facebook Facebook nobody calls it
[__] meta are you noises are you on
meta although my grandma posted on meta
they don't even know what it's they
think it's Facebook why are we just like
cow Towing to a guy who's just like Hey
we're gonna make and I don't I'm not
talking [__] about Elon I have I know
nothing about Elon except for that he
owns Twitter and also he put a car in
[__] space that's it that's all I
know and Tesla's I know the Teslas are
they're just they look so bad they're so
ugly that's it you know
but they're good for the environment and
they go fast this is literally all I
know about Elon Musk
um
could be the world's best to anyone's
time at my show at The Comedy Store I
[__] ripped it it's all good but
um yeah
and uh
but what was the deal we're just gonna
call it X
because you know uh-uh I'm calling it
Twitter dude I never heard my friends
call it X and the media is just like
Elon posted on X that X is nope
not doing it dude
not gonna do it
let's look at this Mitch McConnell thing
is there a video here McConnell
I I saw it and first of all he's a frog
that's fine no he's a tur he's a turtle
and that's fine turtle out of his shell
and that's okay like you know I don't
wanna
but he is and it's okay you know and he
knows it right
why did he freeze
I know he hasn't said
but like why what's the reason
maybe he is just
90. even said
like how old is he
81 run out of that frightening moment in
Washington today Senate
alarmed his colleagues and many watching
when he froze political news conference
Garrett Hague now I wish more guys would
freeze and think about what the hell
they're gonna say by the way you ever
see that clip with um what's a Canadian
[__] King what's his name
do they have a king uh Trudeau where
they were just like what do you think
Donald Trump and he's just like
oh
funny you should ask and everyone's like
oh dummy no dude that's good that's good
think about what you're gonna say
everyone just talks and [__] you have
any one of these politicians talk they
don't even [__] answer the question
I haven't even seen this yet to be
honest by 19 seconds of Silence
interrupted himself returning to concern
for the health of Senate minority leader
here we go who appeared to freeze up as
he began all right
well good afternoon everyone
uh we're on a path to finishing the NDA
Harrison Ford
this week has been good by powers in
cooperation
and a string of uh
he's too old
hey he's too old
I'm too old 19 seconds of death so
gangster dude that is so good this is so
good he's the mod he's basically Dave
Chappelle Dave Chappelle could do this
and still hold attention he held
attention this is amazing dude Mitch
McConnell is the Dave Chappelle of
politicians this is awesome that he did
that and he's a turtle and that's fine
uh right then was what he was thinking
is where's Michelle that's what he was
thinking dude
um
you know what he's thinking where's
where's Splinter that's what he was
thinking
and you're always thinking I'm hungry
for pizza that's what he was thinking
dude
uh our Bebop and Rocksteady here that's
what he's thinking that's what he's
thinking and that's okay you know he's
looking April O'Neill's titties are so
hot you know he's a kid that's it I love
that yellow jump [__] shirt on her
jumpsuit on her that's what he was
thinking and that's okay
you know
but
um
he's 80. he's over 80.
everyone over 80. no dude straight up
and I'm serious everyone over 80 retire
100 immediately effective immediately
when the aliens do come down I hope that
that's what they you're too old everyone
over 75 retire immediately dude did you
see Indiana Jones I didn't but did you
see clips of it I did what's it look
like he's too old Harrison Ford you're
too old retire dude you're so tired
when they said what was it where's the
number one place you'd love to be right
now in on the red carpet and Harrison
Ford said home it's been a long time
since I've been home hey billionaire go
home
hey dude if you want to be going home be
home what's the reason baby what's the
reason you're still out man hey enjoy
all your children and your children's
children and your children's Children's
children's children because you got them
because you're too old what you doing
making Indiana Jones seven
news flash it's gonna suck anyway
Harrison
what you doing
you're a good actor stop
hey time to hang it up dude
I was watching Tulsa King sliced alone
he's killing it he's like 80.
it's still in the same bowling league
favorite line
you can tell them we're in the same
bowling league
anyone over 80 retired I'm serious dude
and also stop driving for [__] sake
dude I saw like an 80 year old driving
the other day and I was like it was so
slow and he didn't know where he was and
it's like dude the rule for driving is
after you turn 65 every year you have to
do a test the test is having a ball
thrown at you if you catch it you get to
keep your license if you drop it you get
one more chance bend down pick it up if
you can't do that you get no driver's
license anymore
it's insane dude
I mean my dad's 75 and he's good he's
he's spry and even he [__] backed out
of the driveway and hit my mom's car he
[__] hit two cars his car in my mom's
car at the same time and he's good
he's chilling
Mitch McConnell you think that I mean
imagine it's going behind a [__]
wheel thank God he doesn't drive he has
drivers you know
at least he'd be drunk so you'd be
looking to be like oh well you know
that's a turtle so that's okay
uh
uh it's crazy all these people are dying
dude from Angus Cloud to Pee-wee Herman
Angus Cloud huh
he died
he was on that show uh Epiphany or
euphoria
[Music]
that's what's up oh this [__] Bro oh
this guy I wouldn't see now I I didn't
know he was until now and now I want to
be his friend that's so dope oh that's
so good such incredibly emotional strong
reactions to the finale
um
uh tell them uh
that's what's up you know what I'm
saying the sexiest man a lot well okay
he died but the sexiest man I've ever
seen in history uh didn't even wow
that's gangster dude uh a Tom that's
what's up man bro that's so cool dude
not even joking your reaction when you
first read the script I go like this
that's what's up
oh God damn dude this guy's dripping I
mean
oh dude I love it put him to the test
dude well part of the script dude
the [__] Rhine the the the the the
Brads
the final episode
oh yeah I was uh oh hell yeah I was I
was kind of tripping I'm like oh
that's wow oh okay so he died of drugs
right
had to have been
I was kind of tripping
this guy oh man now see if I saw this
interview I would [__] watch
everything he did and now it sucks he
died where do you hope the show goes
from here
all been emotional for you
how tell me Mac Miller
oh
whoa this guys
awesome go have fun tonight anybody
you're excited to see
everybody I'm excited to see everybody I
love everybody
and what's next for you leaving
oh this guy's cool man
[__] I don't know taking pictures or
whatnot
he says no thank you
oh my God the what what this person said
it's not a bizarre interview that's just
how he is he wasn't raised in Hollywood
he's a real person come on
I mean yeah dude that's great I wish
more guys were like this for real I I
dude if I ever make it back into
Hollywood which you know
I if I do I'm just gonna do it they
don't
I I bro you thought you seemed real
oh no
no no no no
you haven't seen real until I get back
into Hollywood dude
my shit's gonna be so real
it's gonna be a [__] I'm they're
gonna call me a heart attack that's how
real I am oh here comes [__] heart
attack Chris that's how it really is
dude don't you don't want to interview
him unless you want to get stuck off the
realness do you want to get stuck off
the realness what's that mean uh go
ahead ask me a few questions
hey Chris what's up uh are you excited
to be do uh are you excited to be here
for this movie
uh nah I'd rather see sound of freedom
[__] what's that Meme where the
glasses go over the thing in [__] one
two three and the foe what is it
no no yeah yeah where it go work
[Music]
the [__] uh
wow
[Music]
it's this Essen developed or whatever
the [__] it's the deal double g
wow you picked the wrong word to do it
yo Chris are you excited to be here nope
oh hell yeah dude Chris you excited to
be back in Hollywood just excited to be
getting that money don't really care
about it other than that dunk
hey Chris what do you think about your
cast members I only liked one of them
and then I name them
what do you think about the director he
was fine I could have done it
also didn't have fun on Army of the Dead
it was too hot we did takes for too long
and the [__] movie is probably bad
didn't ever see it
I still have pictures of me in uniform I
might post them one day
wait Chris what do you think of the ah
[__] it releases Zack Snyder Crystal cut
I stole the movie good thing that they
could cut me out of it
think
hey Chris what do you think of the movie
I haven't been the same since people
Herman died
dude PB Herman died I love I love PeeWee
Herman it is so crazy man if he did that
respect people I think he's great
and I don't even give a [__] really
about his uh Scandal wet back when it
was like 19 something
got arrested for jacking off in the
movie theater or whatever and uh you
know he was at a porn theater he should
have done it you know it's like he's not
the other one doing it by the way so uh
and then everyone just forgot dude if he
did that [__] Tuesday if he did that
[__] you know four years ago boom that's
it that would have been it people would
have been like people would have been
like I mean he would have been done for
not that he was really doing [__] now he
was great though dude a [__] R.I.P
Herman rip PB Herman
um but yeah man isn't it so crazy that
nobody gives a [__] about stuff unless
it's now that's how you know that the
metoo movement is a little bit
da
like dude come on man you know
uh yeah
but it's all good rest in peace people
Herman we love we love them man got it
that guy was so funny
you know
he was a girlfriend and he did that that
is so funny bro haha dude that's
actually genius
wow that's some Beavis and butt head
level funny [__]
like dude how did he how did he know you
know
and then he dude you know his his thing
was an adult show and then people were
like just like let's make it for kids
and then it became a huge hit people's
playhouse
uh that is crazy
he had cancer I guess uh
see this is the stuff I that drives me
nuts and I don't mean it's his fault
this is the Public's fault when he says
he writes please accept my apology for
not going public with what I've been
facing the last six years Mr Reuben said
in a statement released with the
announcement of his death I've always
felt a huge amount of love and respect
for my friends fan support I have loved
you all so much and enjoyed making art
for you dude he doesn't owe you that
[__] man he probably just wants to be
alone and do that thing like shout out
to [__] Chadwick Boseman that's his
name right the guy who died of like he
just was like out he was just peace out
did he even say anything he didn't say
anything when he had it and then when he
didn't have it he just pieced out
which is really the way to the the
that's a gangster way to do it
he didn't say [__] dude
it just goes [__]
oh
peace out
um
but yeah God bless uh Pee-wee Herman he
was the best
he was the best
look at this
basketballnetwork.net worst website
look at this the Shaquille O'Neal on why
he believes the World is Flat this is
crazy I mean that tracks you know
because Shaq although he's a good
business man
I don't know if he's the uh
Brightest Bulb I don't know
Kylie Irving made headlines in 2017 when
he said the Earth is flat not round
while it was Kai who um Drew plenty of
fly for the statement he wasn't the only
NBA dude it's so NBA basketball player
to [__] think the world is flat
a month or so after Irving made his
controvers remarks form of Los Angeles
Lakers great Shaquille O'Neal
oh this was a month after he made it I
didn't hear about this
what that's crazy why is it news now
speaking at his the big podcast Shaq
said I'm from I'm from Jersey and it's
just how we think
so listen I drive from coast to coast
and this [__] is flat to me said O'Neill
I'm just saying I drive from Florida to
California all the time and it's flat to
me
I do not go up and down at 360 degree
angles
and all this stuff
about gravity have you looked outside
Atlanta lately and seen all these
buildings you mean to tell me that China
is under us China is under us it's not
the World is Flat
oh my God
how is this a real thing to say
why my whole thing about the world being
flat
what the conspiracy
it's just one big Psych
it's ah the world's flat they're lying
to us okay why
what is the government board
NASA is just they don't they want to do
a prank what's the reason do you know
why would they [__] make it up
they might have said well I'll say it's
a star shape who gives a [__]
what's it what what's the reason for for
making it flat
you know the government dude they'd just
be lying and pranking
I I just it's so entirely stupid to just
make dude I was watching this thing uh
called the truth the the
um
the
cost of I think it was the cost of Truth
truth
uh
uh movie I think that's what it was
called the price of Truth
was it the price of Truth
I don't know what it was was it let me
look it up
no no the price of Truth nope nope it
wasn't a movie it was a documentary and
it was on max
whatever the [__] you call it now Max or
HBO Max it took out the HBO part now
it's called Max
um
I'm just gonna start calling PornHub hub
the the thing was saying how
it is so crazy how like this
dude like all these conspiracy theories
they just and like look some of them are
okay yeah they're not all wrong like
there are some conspiracy theories that
are real like the JFK one
that didn't happen the way they said it
happened and that's 100 very obvious
because it's not you can't shoot them
[__] it dude the guy didn't have a
sniper rifle you know or Diddy I don't
even know but then they caught him and
they killed him it's like so
coincidental but dude if you think
podesta is in the basement of a [__]
pizza shop in DC just molesting your CR
like dude how about this get a better
area you know
in the uh
dude I watched this thing I forget it
was on Max it was like a a documentary
this poor guy who owns Comet Pizza is
just like yeah man some guy just said on
Reddit that we that we have a dungeon
where we molest kids and so
now people were coming in the shop with
guns telling us to show us the dungeon
and like these [__] mental I'm so duh
like men mental
health is real like you need to
understand it and and we need to get
better as a people but like dude when
when there's guys with guns coming in
your shop because they're mental it's
like there's it's so annoying dude it's
it's so I would be like as scared as I
would be as if somebody came to my uh
establishment with a gun because they
thought something was happening that
wasn't happening
I would be so much more annoyed I would
be like oh dude really man
you know what just shoot me you [__]
like you just you 4chan [__] Reddit
reading [__] that just you just
think that this happened because some
guy said it
you cook
have a [__] pepperoni pizza sit down
like it's so you know how annoying that
we got to deal with these [__] the
internet is so good it's so awesome but
it's so annoying for these [__]
losers that it for uh that they're just
like hey like I could just start a [__]
right now hey you know [__] um the uh
American Idol doesn't really happen
it's actually not Ryan Seacrest he died
20 years ago
and it's been a AI or a robot since then
Simon Cowell is actually a 400 fat
pound woman now he transitioned and dude
you say that at the right time in the
right
[__] Chan eight chant whatever
they're on now 16 Chan dude you get you
get that going in the right time it's a
board news day
in [__] five years someone shoots
Simon Cowell because what some guy said
on the internet
the Internet isn't real and now we have
to deal with real consequences
it's just so it's so
Beefcake annoying dude
it's so annoying
and now we got because of this [__]
Shaquille O'Neal
and other basket dude
they're just like well you know the
Court's flat it's not hard to what about
roads aren't flat
when you drive from coast to coast what
about how they're not flat though I mean
some of it's flat but what about it
while you're going like this
why the my whole point is why why would
that happen why would the government lie
about how the world how the Earth is
flat why would why why would they have a
[__] dungeon under a pizza place why
would it be there
Calvin's doing Pac-Man right outside the
door outside the door he's got this new
thing called the toilet morph
man I don't know what happened with the
toilet more the skippity skibety toilet
morphs
you ever seen this oh have you seen it
because of my son or have you seen it
okay dude
this is the scariest thing
and it just started I think
and
what's the D dude look at this
this is skibity toilet 54 this came out
12 hours ago it's got
13 million views dude
is it music this is my comeback nah get
out of here
come on Purdue Global get out of here
we have
this is the scariest thing I've ever
seen in my life
I mean this guy's face is coming out of
toilet oh
why is this something
dude my son loves this [__] I mean this
one's way too violent for him
oh
what is like a top comment on this thing
I mean look at the [__] [__] time
that they
somebody said I love this episode bro
wow oh dude shout out to the cameraman
who's brave enough to show his feelings
ah
what is going on
what the [__]
um
I don't understand but my son loves it
dude and he'll just walk around the
house all day skippity skippity knee
kneeps give me disease
um I don't understand uh come on I'm
trying to [__] send this to you so
you can know which one it is
um
I don't get this at all but I don't get
I guess I don't know
okay I guess I don't have anything to
say about that except for what was I
talking about
I can't even remember
look at Kyrie apologizing for
saying the World is Flat
you said you're joking and then you
weren't joking so which is it which side
are you on well I mean uh hopefully
after this I'm done answering good let's
clear it up for good you never have to
be asked again you were going to ask me
regardless but I think so I think the
the like what you say and what you do
and how you mean it at the time I was
like huge in the conspiracies
everybody's been there
I mean not really
yo what's going on with our world you
know like you click a YouTube click and
it goes like How Deep The Rabbit Hole
goes
but not really though dude not really
though you dork you know
not really though
yeah you talk about the world's being
flat dude
you start telling all your friends like
you all did you see that watch this
video I'm telling you
know at the time it was like I you know
you like innocent in it but you realize
the effect of
the place and even if you believe but
also why who gives a [__] if people why
is this who cares if people believe this
who cares this one doesn't matter let
them believe it so they don't believe
the other [__]
uh yeah the world's flat oh yeah yeah
that's cool yeah for sure dude oh yeah I
get it man now walk away man it's not
flapping
yeah it's flat yeah but the world's flat
oh yeah it's not harming anyone it's not
flat but yeah yeah it's flat dude I get
it man it's so
hey Hills
it's like you just you're like well
don't come out and say that stuff that's
for intimate conversations because no
it's not perception while you're
received it just changes like dude the
Earth is flat is not for intimate
conversations you know
no I'm actually a smart-ass individual
like smart ass
in it so it was like at the time just
didn't realize the effect right I was
definitely at that time like I'm a big
conspiracy there so you can't tell me
anything
so yeah I'm sorry about all that you
know for all the science teachers
everybody coming up to me like you know
I gotta reteach my whole curriculum I'm
sorry I apologize that's cool he's a
cool dude I like him
that's nice to say that was he the one
that put no he's not the one that put
that stuff that you hate in documentary
that's not him right that's the other
guy
Curry handsome Michelle
it could be that handsome if I tried
um
this is a Subway to give free sandwiches
for life
just to one person who alleged who who
agrees to legally change the name to
Subway I mean dude
sad everything about this is this
what kind of fat [__] would do this you
know
hey it's me
can I get the [__] roast beef oh hey
Subway
how about that dude the world's so big
there was somebody that was like I mean
I was gonna do that anyway I might as
well do it and get the free sandwiches
somebody that identifies as a Subway
right so
um
the winner will receive 750 to cover the
cost of Legally changing their name
along with fifty thousand dollars in
Subway gift cards returning the rules
that's nah dude I don't want that's so
annoying that you gotta carry around a
[__] gift dude if I legally change my
name to Subway you put posters all over
the [__] place in the Subways and
when I get in there they just make me
whatever the [__] I want hey I'm this
there I am me Subway give me the turkey
with the [__] white American I really
like
you know what I mean to have to actually
be with the card here can I see your
driver's license yeah here Subway Delia
I like this too the winner will receive
750 dude it's so easy to win
the win will be charging at random how
many people are gonna be doing this
imagine changing to Subway and it's not
and you don't win
you're just the guy Subway
ah [__] I'm Subway Jones
wow the click bait of this [__] look
at the click bait look 31 celebrities
who have destroyed their looks look at
this one drop makes me so productive I
get a day's work done in three hours
this is my favorite
NHL's NHL player's wife is hands down
the most beautiful woman in the world
like like it's not
like you that's not math it's an opinion
that's just like your opinion man
um I wanted to talk about one other
thing and I can't [__] remember God
damn it dude
it's like skip it is neef dude
let's look at the deserved scales here
we go deserve it scales
rapper wanted to jump like an athlete oh
dude there's never been anyone more out
of shape than rappers for real
oh
[__] this song keeps going died
what is
[Music]
I mean dude
uh Rick lost dude why is he
the worst show dude why did he jump like
there were people in the crowd there
were two people in the crowd so out of
shape dude I [__] can't stand when
someone's so out of shape you know
like work out or something
I eat pasta
I eat pizza but I work out I know my
metabolism is kind of this [__] but also
like
deserve at scale ten no nine
running up on lead singer there you go
that's beautiful
don't run up on that [__] hell
yeah dude
he ran up on him [__] yeah barreled him
down dude oh that must have hurt God
damn that's awesome good job guy
[Music]
look at the
nah I didn't deserve it get him off
that guy deserved every inch of that
[__] huge
Frank Thomas looking guy smashing him
into [__] the next universe
nine these are good ones here we go
um stairway slide
up sounds like it could be [__]
hilarious
here we go
what happened oh [__] idiots dude
just got two inches shorter oh sat the
[__] down I love how there were pillows
there and he just moved them out of the
way to just get [__]
smashed in his anus
oh that's an eight
I think they actually let's see it again
God damn these guys that's a
eight
let's go this one do you get that
Spider-Man one okay
here we go with this one sapo Guapo on
YouTube
sapo guapo
is this one on Tick Tock it's a good
thing it's taking so long to do it
man oh here we go here's the Spider-Man
one yeah
it says bro is not Spider-Man
there we go
come on
nope don't want to sign it thank you
very much don't want to sign in
thank you very much don't want to sign
in just want to see it
come on dude
here we go baby okay
throws Spiderman
throws a [__]
cord over the lamp post and now going
upside down a spider
oh the noise dude smashed his head
against the pole
super super
heroes in real life that is a [__]
nine it would be a 10 but it looked like
he probably died
oh my gosh dude
Spider-Man
somebody wrote Under it Spider-Man
forgot my home
that is so bad
come on play again
look they're so jacked
up so Mexican
oh so bad also this isn't even cool this
whole thing like you're so dorky it's
rope dude you're not Spider-Man
nine bro I thought a car was gonna hit
him when I first saw that and I was like
oh no dude
um
ah damn that's so that is some gangster
[__]
and that's why there's no Spider-Man
wcgw playing
minieval Knievel medieval Knievel in a
parking lot
what is that oh [__]
oh no
I'm like oh yeah
they ramped the thing how did it [__]
make that much of a oh yeah what is that
thing a toy
you know it
oh that [__] up that car dude
that must I hope it was theirs God that
sucks if it wasn't you know they didn't
tell anyone
and they still post it and they're gonna
get caught love it
that's not it's they don't deserve it
because it wasn't theirs it was theirs
they deserve it [__] full-on tent
why is that thing so heavy
make it lighter
skating down a ramp in a parking lot but
we know how this ends
oh no this idiot
that dude if that was me
I would die
I'd be on the way I died
on the way hitting the thing guys I died
Eddie Murphy the way he's laughing
dude I hate dudes that laugh at that
[__]
um that's a nine these are good ones wow
sad huh
okay I like how people are like hey this
is just your run-of-the-mill skateboard
thing somebody said nothing this is what
happens bro I gotta understand more
about parkour I definitely need to
understand more about parkour because
parkour seems like you just [__] have
no ankles and no wrists because you
broke them
what is he in mud
you can't get out of the mud ew dude
that was actually pretty impressive how
he jumped on that one
[__] up that one and now he's gonna
build ew dude
he's just in a bunch of [__] elephant
[__]
that's so gross he did that's a 10. [__]
it [__] that
ruin the shoes
why are those guys on there dude
quicksand gonna die
quicksand in the city
um wow
these are all nines these are really
that one's not a that one was okay he he
could have it could have been a little
funnier but
um
look at this all right well let's do
some misconnections
looking for the couples for friends La
Puente I'm a male and I'm looking for a
couple to hang out same deal as always I
just sit and watch respectfully I mean
respectfully you know let me know I can
help I can help for your time let's talk
dude I'm a male and I'm looking for a
couple to hang out same deal as always I
just sit and watch respectfully why does
he say same deal as always it's new
people same deal as old you may have
heard of me I'm am looking for the
couples for friends look I just sit
respectfully I wear a suit I come I
watch you do some you know different
positions he nuts all up in you and then
we go home we go to our separate houses
man that's all I need
you know he jerks off you know what I
mean what's respectfully
girls come over let's play Compton's
dangerous
come over let's order some food and have
a good time I'm Hispanic skinny and 32.
send pics and please be serious let's
make it happen wow this guy's so
positive nothing bad has ever happened
to this guy in his life
what I'm sorry there's a website that
what that's him
and you can just really and for sex
well I don't even mention sex but
they'll probably blow me great perfect
where is it girls come over let's play
Compton come over let's order some food
have a good time I'm Hispanic I'm skinny
and 32.
why are they not responding
only fat dudes are
um here's another one looking for a lady
to eat out right to it right offered
from
la
I mean that's the least you could do
you come over to me I come over to you
or we can do it in my car wow so
desperate single white guys here in good
shape
so desperate dude
this one says and I know this is a slur
but looking for Tran a [__] that's
what it says in Palmdale go figure
where they at period is they a hangout
or something
wow
so if you are one hit him up Palmdale
grandmother help is missed Los Angeles I
miss my grandmother she would have me
help her and do things for her if you
see this please respond thank you I mean
what dude
you want someone to do it or are you
just is this just a [__] are you in
therapy I miss my grandmother and she
would have me help her and do things for
her if you see this with something like
he wants to help you is he looking to
get paid or is this a kink thing sup hey
guys sup you all right
um all right look thanks guys appreciate
you uh Charlotte Knoxville Little Rock
Nashville Alberta I'll see you soon uh
and Brea and Irvine thank you uh and if
you uh want to watch thanks for watching
this it's the YouTube episode if you
want to watch the end of if you want to
watch the rest of it the uncut the
uncensored the uh extra long episodes of
congratulations go onto patreon.com
crystalia and you can also go
uh if you do that you can get uh you get
one episode extra a month and it is
actually there's like 31 or 32 there now
so go Benjamin patreon.com thank you
very much
[Music]
thank you